so this video is about the multiple
choice section on the ap us history exam
and now i know you're thinking
whoa kim this is a multiple choice
section how much help could we possibly
need with this either you know the
answer or you don't
oh contrarimonami
thankfully the multiple choice section
on this exam is not just a laundry list
of facts that you know or you don't know
or you just leave blank
what's really great about the way that
these questions are designed is that
they really reward you for having
intuition about what's going on in any
time period in american history so you
might not necessarily need to know a pop
quiz of facts about slavery in the 19th
century but
if you have a general idea of who the
major players are what the major ideas
are then you'll actually prosper in this
section more than you might think so
let's take a look at these quotes over
here
now each of the questions on the
multiple choice portion of the exam will
relate back to a series of quotes like
this or maybe a chart or a political
cartoon the good news is that they're
not just independent of each other
they're always going to relate back to
that chart that graph that political
cartoon so
these two quotes
are actually related to four questions
and each set of quotes or cartoon will
have about two to four questions that go
with it so you should really spend a lot
of time
reading these documents and reading them
carefully and before you even go about
trying to answer the questions try to
get a sense of who the people are who
are speaking what their main points are
and how they're making their argument
before you even take a stab at any of
the questions so let's do that with what
we have here
so this is a real practice question from
the ap exam
and it consists of two quotes one from
james henry hammond
and one from frederick douglass now
douglas you've probably heard of before
james henry hammond maybe not so much
all right well first let's think about
where they are in time so we've got
hammond in 1845 and douglas in 1852 so
it's the late antebellum period getting
into the period just before the civil
war we know there are a lot of arguments
about slavery and whether it should
exist at this time period so all right
that's a pretty easy baseline for where
we are in time okay now where are we in
space well we know that james henry
hammond is from south carolina
what about frederick douglass do we have
any clues as to where he is
well there's nothing listed here
but let's move into who these people
actually are so we've got frederick
douglass and he's a pretty key figure in
american history so frederick douglass
we know
was a former enslaved person who escaped
and
he was very active in the abolitionist
movement
the abolitionists were
the group of mostly northern
intellectuals who believed that slavery
should be ended right this minute
everywhere in the united states if not
the world so this is probably a pretty
good clue that
we're looking at someone from the north
what about james henry hammond have you
heard of him before probably not but we
do know some things about him we know
that he's in south carolina
so southern part of the country
and we know that he is a governor so we
can reasonably assume that he's pretty
elite
um we can be pretty certain since this
is before the civil war that he's white
so you see that i'm making some
assumptions about who james henry
hammond is here i i think he's probably
a wealthy person i think he's probably
white and you may be saying to yourself
whoa whoa whoa what if james henry
hammond was the one exception to the
rule and he was from the working class
or he was that one african-american
governor that we never talk about from
before the civil war
basically the question you're asking is
could this be a trick and the answer is
generally no almost never is the ap us
history exam going to try to trick you
with that one strange exception to the
rule because they want you to build this
intuition they want to say all right
what do you know about american history
and how can you fit these questions into
that rubric you even have kind of a clue
that you probably shouldn't know who
this guy is because they have to explain
who he is in the first place right they
have to say this was a governor of south
carolina whereas frederick douglass you
can be pretty sure that you've heard of
him and you know what he was about so
trust your instincts here because people
are going to be more or less who they
seem in these circumstances
all right let's finally read these
quotes still though a slave holder i
freely acknowledge my obligations as a
man and i am bound to treat humanely the
fellow creatures whom god has entrusted
to my charge it is certainly in the
interest of all and i am convinced it is
the desire of every one of us to treat
our slaves with proper kindness
all right so what is he saying here
first he's saying he
himself is a slave holder so we've got a
good idea of who he is he's a wealthy
white person who owns slaves in the
south
so we can guess that he's probably
pro-slavery
what else is he saying he's saying that
slaveholders should treat enslaved
people with
kindness all right he says it he's
convinced it's the desire of every one
of us well this doesn't quite seem to
jive with what we know about slavery in
the south it's a cruel and terrible
institution so it sounds like hammond
might be making kind of an excuse for
slavery
or at least say maybe slavery is not so
bad
and i think there's one other thing kind
of lurking in here which is this idea
that
god has trusted fellow creatures to his
charge
so he's almost saying that god made the
system of slavery that the way things
are is the way that god wanted them to
be so this is almost a religious
argument
for slavery saying god wanted it to be
this way god has entrusted these people
to his care so what's frederick douglass
saying here he's saying
standing with god and the crushed and
bleeding slave on this occasion i will
in the name of humanity which is
outraged and in the name of liberty
which is fettered in the name of the
constitution and bible which are
disregarded and trampled upon dare to
call and question and denounce slavery
the great sin and shame of america well
i'm going to go out on a limb here and
say that douglas does not agree
with hammond
so
i think these two
quotes are are pretty much diametrically
opposed so where hammond says that god
entrusted enslaved people to his care
douglas is saying he's standing with god
and the crushed bible
to say that slavery is
condemned
by christianity
what else is he saying well he's saying
liberty and the constitution are being
trampled upon so
that there's a patriotic appeal maybe
also
for why
the declaration of independence and the
idea of all men are created equal is not
compatible with slavery so while hammond
is saying oh i think that all people who
own slaves desire to treat them kindly
and god has entrusted us with slaves
this is the natural order meant by the
almighty douglas is saying no this is
the great sin and shame of america it is
not a christian institution and it is
not an institution which is compatible
with the ideals of the united states so
we've got a ton of information out of
these documents and we haven't even
looked at a multiple choice question yet
all right are you ready to take some on
let's do it
all right this is an actual ap practice
question
and the first thing you want to do when
you're approaching one of these
questions is to read it really carefully
so the excerpt from james henry hammond
is most clearly an example of which of
the following developments in the
mid-19th century all right so we're only
looking at hammond
and we're specifically thinking about
the mid-19th century so put ourselves
there in time that kind of 1850s era
let's go through the possible answers
one by one and if we don't like
something we will cross it out right
away all right option a the decline of
slavery in southern states as a result
of gradual emancipation laws all right
so
says that slavery was declining
as a result of gradual emancipation loss
well i don't think that can be true
right because if anything slavery is
getting stronger before the civil war i
don't remember any gradual emancipation
laws in the south so let's get rid of
that
all right option b the increasingly
restrictive nature of slavery in the
south enforced by stronger slave codes
well there certainly were more slave
codes in the 1850s and they were pretty
restrictive but is that what the excerpt
is talking about now he's talking about
kindness and that slave owners should
treat their slaves kindly so that's
probably not the right one but let's
leave it on the table for now just in
case there's not a better answer the
expanding use of moral arguments by
northern anti-slavery activists well
hammond is a southerner so i'm gonna go
with no
all right option d
the growing tendency among southern
slaveholders to justify slavery as a
positive good yeah i think that's
actually the best option right because
he's saying god intended this
we're trying to treat them with kindness
so it's a very pro-slavery argument made
on the grounds that slavery is a good
institution now it's worth noting that
one of these options option b what it
says is true but it's not a clear
example of what hammond is saying in the
excerpt so make sure that you're
answering the question that you're
actually being asked not just looking
for what could be factually true among
the answers
all right i think this is enough for
this video but stay tuned to the next
video and we'll do a few more examples